es una situación de alto riesgo en
brasil ningún otro país del mundo
registra actualmente un mayor número de
muertos al día por kobe 19 de janeiro
junto con sao paulo la ciudad más
golpeada por la pandemia en una nación
con más de 13 millones de casos
confirmados y más de 322 mil muertos
sólo eeuu supera a brasil en esos dos
indicadores una crisis que en estas
favelas de sao paulo tiene un impacto
económico me da mucha tristeza mi temor
es que mis hijas pasen hambre tengo
tanto miedo de no tener suficiente para
comprar cosas para la casa una de ellas
aún es menor de 18 años es una
manifestación de un movimiento que
representa a las 10 favelas más grandes
de brasil denuncian como insuficiente el
anuncio del gobierno de entregarles un
pago de 27 dólares al mes
en belo horizonte quienes se quejan son
las trabajadoras sexuales en su caso
para pedirse de incluidas en el grupo de
prioridad en la vacunación somos parte
de un grupo de prioridad porque estamos
en contacto con varios tipos de personas
y nuestras vidas están en riesgo esa
vacunación avanza de manera lenta pero
el lunes llego a un umbral que da
esperanza 20 millones de personas ya han
recibido una primera dosis de la vacuna
algo que equivale a cerca del 10 por
ciento de la población en medio de un
plan que empezó el 17 de enero